did the Star Wars sequel trilogy give us
one big bad for the price of two with
the release of Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker imminent the rumor mill is
working overtime and the latest nugget
has to do with the late Supreme Leader
Snoke Emperor Palpatine and the
relationship between the two characters
the rumor comes from fansite making Star
Wars which has been a fairly reliable
source of inside information so be
warned that potential spoilers for rise
of Skywalker are ahead ever since his
first appearance in Star Wars The Force
awakens the identity of Snoke has been
shrouded in mystery where did he come
from how did he come to assume control
of the first order after the fall of the
Empire and what is his interest in kylo
Ren rise of Skywalker will presumably
answer all of those questions but making
Star Wars might have answered one of
them for us just a little bit early the
websites alleged spoiler has to do with
a scene that supposedly takes place on
the dead planet of EXO Gul where Emperor
Palpatine has been in hiding wait you
say stroking your chin I thought he died
geez grandpa take a chill pill but ya
know we still have no explanation as to
just how old pal says returned for the
purposes of this rumor however it's
neither here nor there
the Emperor is confronted by kylo Ren
who we assume has located the old dude
with the help of one of those heavily
rumored wayfinder devices that are said
to be central to the flicks plot Ren is
skeptical that Palpatine even is who he
says he is but he's shaken to discover
that the Emperor is keeping several
clones of Snoke in vats in his lair
their conversation becomes more and more
confrontational with Ren's anger
starting to bubble to the surface and
Palpatine becoming more and more annoyed
that this young upstart doesn't grasp
the enormity of what's going on here
when Ren finally invokes Snoke by name
Palpatine makes a startling proclamation
I am Snoke well we didn't see that
coming okay maybe we sort of saw it
coming but we were never exactly sure
the question that remained
so assuming that this rumor is accurate
and that the scene actually exists is
whether or not Palpatine is speaking
literally could it be that Palpatine has
actually found a way to transfer his
consciousness into the body of another
being this might explain why Snoke was
so keen to groom Wren perhaps the young
guy was actually being prepped to become
Palpatine's next vessel hey if we were
trapped inside that horrifying bag of
bones that was Snoke we'd be keen to
hook ourselves up with the younger far
more aesthetically pleasing and
broad-shouldered body too however don't
forget that Palpatine has employed this
phrasing before during the events of
Star Wars Revenge of the Sith while
still holding the title of Supreme
Chancellor and before his transformation
into a walking breathing jump-scare
Palpatine was confronted by Jedi Master
Mace Windu over having concealed his
identity as the Sith Lord Darth Sidious
attempting to place Palpatine under
arrest
Windu informs him that the Senate will
decide his fate whereupon Palpatine
coolly replies I am the Senate obviously
Palpatine is prone to speaking in such
metaphorical terms and it's pretty
likely that in revealing his
relationship to Snoke he's doing so
again rather than admitting to having
physical control over the supreme leader
he's instead simply stating that Snoke
was his puppet a puppet which he happens
to have several copies of laying around
in vats which Ren can plainly see of
course it must be reiterated that this
report should be taken not with a grain
of salt but with several heaping
tablespoons making star wars as sources
are as anonymous as sources get and
while their description of the scene is
pretty darn detailed that still doesn't
preclude the possibility that someone
pulled it wholesales straight out of
their keisters if it is accurate though
it may help to explain a few things such
as the degenerated unsettlingly melty
look of Snoke and why the heck the
supreme leader was so easily and
unceremoniously killed halfway through
the last Jedi we find it pretty easy to
believe that that old puppet master
Palpatine has been laying low pulling
strings throughout the sequel films so
we're going to go ahead and rate this
rumor seems pretty legit fortunately we
don't have to
a way to find out whether we're right
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker the
conclusion to the nine film Skywalker
saga finally hits the big screen on
December 20th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]